for the raise it's going to be ryan
yarbrough getting a few extra days of
rest
lamenting you didn't do it sooner and a
cut in the midst
a couple of breaking balls took care of
him
three pitches one gone
a fly ball golfed out to right and
margot this will land
fair santander busting it for a second
and he is in there
ball kicks away for the shortstop walls
but anthony will hold as it's backed up
by diaz
a double well placed for anthony
santander his 11th of the year
and there you go back with it again
got him this time and kagan aiken now he
did pitch a third of an inning here
last year but this is kind of his debut
as far as starting
there is a five-pitch walk from aitkin
to margot
and ball four and then when you're
throwing 3-1 change-ups
get them off the playing field there's a
ground ball to shortstop galvez will
hesitate balayka onto first into two
the orioles turn the double play six to
four to three
galvez to the leica to mount castle
aiken
escapes the jam and he gets to chase
there out of hayes
and him out in front chasing strikeout
number three already
and i'm going to tell you what if this
oriole lineup doesn't get real
disciplined real fast it's going to be a
long night look how far he's getting
them to chase pitches off the plate
3-2 to franco and he got him and again
he got him reaching on the change if you
had a problem with it you could meet him
around the corner that's right
oh this is going to take quite a play oh
and
yarbrough looking for that bag
and boy it appeared the raves were going
to pull that off
oh my god let's take a look i mean he
ends up a little short but does he bump
it oh i think he did
we're getting close to a decision here
oh
they're gonna say he's safe drake a
couple of home runs
who knows where maybe it'll be in st p
mancini down the left field line this
ball
is good there's your extra base hit
trey mancini a two-run home run
kept fair down the line and left his
third home run against ryan
yarbrough this year well actually you
know where the oils stay they have a
golf course and this is kind of the
what trey does i don't know if he went
out and hit a couple of
tee shots today but he tees off on look
like a cutter
he is hit off race pitching this year
and all lefties liner into center
that will stay up and keermeyer goes
down
a little slide to make that catch and
retires the side
that's a shot back into left field hayes
on the run going to be off the bottom of
the wall
he gets a great carom right back to him
and they will hold samino to a single
ground ball that's going to sneak
through in the center field a base hit
you can go on and on a swing and miss
ball popping away
genito is going to try to advance it he
is in there
he's in there safely back around to the
top of the order manuel margot
well this is going to be the 10th pitch
of this at bat
the ground ball to short they'll get
wanted
second the run's gonna score and safe at
first
board with some speed over there
and he shoots it up the gap left center
field
the rosarito is gonna go to third rosso
will dig for two
and he is out trying to stretch it into
a double
try to get in their head first and
around the tag
vallejo put it on him though the rays
have the potential tying around a third
one out and hits a high fly ball
that ball is going to get out of here
wow i'll tell you he hit that ball way
out of here
boy for a moment it appeared that it
might hit one of the rings up there
and somehow made its way all the way out
and into the seats and right center
field a one-two pitch and lau
has given the rays the lead
[Applause]
and the response is a change-up
long run franco against the shift what a
play
michael bronco had to go a very long way
to track that thing down in the bullpen
and track it down
he did not only that he's gonna high
five the entire bullpen there you go
come on long run nice play
didn't get hurt putting it together but
the average
and a base hit by that third base side
wide open and kier meyer is going to
head for second
and he's in there standing up little
ground ball
normally to the third baseman and he
rolls it into left and has a two base
hit
up here with the chance to pitch in
again
[Music]
he does slide drive base it into left
that's going to score kermeyer
margaux makes the turn and hangs out at
first
rays now have a 4-2 lead
margot comes through with his second run
bad at end of the night
crank out against wells
and a ground ball here to third franco
smothers it up with it another great
play by franco and mount castle did keep
the bag
see if the rays want to take a look at
this one as it stands it ends the inning
franco
heading over to the dugout kevin cash
is going to check and the rays are it
appears
not going to challenge you know nice
range we're on the turf here
and then he gets up and this is even
more impressive with ryan mount castle
oh wait a minute he's never on the back
you know what the rays are going to take
a look at this one actually they did ask
for the review
and because he never ever got the toe
back and of course the only way you
catch that ball is to come off the bag
the question is is it you know are they
gonna is it gonna be definitive enough
certainly looks like it but oh they
can't call him out
wow that is
absolutely it truly is marley's ghost
i'll tell you fairbanks looks good
tonight
the o2 to galvez about to be made here
it is
and a chop to the left side throw to
first in this game is over the rays are
winners tonight
three up three down in the ninth inning
and the rays
come away with a 4-2 victory over
baltimore
to open this three-game series the rays
get their 40th win of the year